hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo
dreimal dürft ihr raten was passiert ist
dreimal dürft ihr raten was war
natürlich hat ich das game jetzt aufgehängt und habe den dande snipe verpasst
Danke Telekom ganz toll
So ein dass ich sowas überhaupt provider nennen darf
Shit weiter oder so shit rider kein provider
Ja Telekom will Dande für sich das ist nice
Tag Telekom
Ja
Noch noch mal den breitbandatlas angucken
Vielleicht habe ich glück das ding ist gerade in letzter minute ins aha gegangen
Und ist jetzt noch beim bieten oder so vielleicht habe ich gerade glück also ich könnte es
Da mit ein paar sekunden könnte ich es packen aber ich glaube ich glaube es nicht
Die wollen dann für sich haben sie gesniped und haben jetzt wieder mein internet eingeschaltet
Oh nice graphics
Oh
Moment ist sie noch nicht drin ist das richtig
Sie ist es richtig dass sie noch nicht drin war die dande
Wissen Sie noch was das für eine war das war nice
Telekom Telekom jetzt neige ich euch die dande weg
Easy Salib easy Salib
Achtung leute easy Salib wahrscheinlich bricht jetzt wieder die verbindung ab
Auf kommann prü
Hat nicht geklappt hat nicht funktioniert
Hast du überhaupt geld ja
Fabian fürs lachen ich habe wieder in willia 160 mille einfach nur durch sinnloses
rumgegrindet ein bisschen gestern und
Bisschen dropplack ja ich war ich weiß auch nicht so genau wo die Kohle herkommt
Du hast das das ding war eben ich habe geld eingesammelt aus dem aus dem marketplace
Hab gestern die ganzen drops noch eingesetzt die ich auch noch hatte und die ich
Vom von von diesem lager dingern gekriegt hat jetzt habe ich wieder 160
mille das geld macht mal wieder kein sound so aber genug telekom geholt
Jetzt jetzt jetzt kommen sie willia bent anhören beste beste musik achtung leute
beste beste musik
beste du du du du du du du du du du du so ich würde jetzt mein zufrieden jetzt wird
weiter gegrindet welche musik hörst du so privat hauptsächlich hard rock
hat die metal sowas in der richtung oder irisch folk ist auch geil so irisches gefiedel
und haftbefehl genau immer
so also ich habe jetzt noch wenn es dann irgendwelche fragen oder sonst was gibt
im chat ich brauche jetzt hier noch 56 minuten zum futtern also jetzt habe ich
zeit
Jetzt bräuchte ich mal Dems immer als.
Was ist auch mal der Unterschied zwischen Peering und Transit?
Also Peering ist, wenn du zu einem anderen Provider hingehst und sagst, hey wollen wir
uns nicht, wollen wir uns nicht peeren, also sprich, du stöpselst ein Kabel von deinem
Router zu seinem, ehrlich gesagt, doch Transit ist halt, ja Transit, halt von Netz zu Netz
so Transit, schlecht erklären, von einem zum anderen, weil irgendeinem gehört das Netz
ja, wo du hin willst, wenn du mit dem nicht gepieert bist, musst du halt das Paket über
andere Wege zu dem Zielnetz kriegen, weil du es ja nicht direkt erreichen kannst von
dir aus, da weiß ich nicht, was dein Cloud Anbieter mit meint, also mit Peering ist normalerweise
gemeint, wenn du dich halt direkt oder mehr oder weniger direkt zusammen stöpselst mit
anderen Providern, Peering ist auf jeden Fall das billigere für dich als Provider, weil
du direkt von deinem Router quasi in das Netz von dem kommst, wo du hin willst, wenn du
mit dem gepieert bist, da musst du keine Transitkosten quasi zahlen oder halt nur das was es dich
kostet, was die selbst kostet.
Ja Sink, ich warte auf was, ich warte darauf, dass ich meinen Sushi fertig gefordert hab,
vielleicht sollte ich das mal einplanten.
Gibt es an Sylvester wieder ein Plant-2-Zombie-Stream, mal gucken, mal gucken.
Das schmeckt echt wieder richtig geil, muss ich sagen, auch wenn das ja im Prinzip was
relativ Simples ist eigentlich, du hast da ein bisschen Reis, da hast du irgendwelche
Fischeier oder sowas drum herum und drinnen noch ein bisschen Zeug, also es schmeckt doch
trotzdem echt geil.
Sink, was ist denn, mit Doban da direkt, klickt nach irgendwelchen, irgend so einem
Pustensaft oder sowas.
Und diese Rolls mit Krebsfleisch sind nochmal eine Steigerung, ne nicht mit Krebsfleisch,
mit Garnelen, sind nochmal eine Steigerung, schmeckt auch echt geil, also war gut was
wir uns da ausgesucht haben.
Weißt du wie man feststellen kann, ab welchem Knotenpunkt das Internet abbricht, also ist
die Frage, lass mal was mit Internetabbrechen gemeint ist, also wenn der Weg von dir zu
deinem Provider schon richtig funktioniert, kannst du auch nicht großartig feststellen
oder wenn es DSL nicht sünkt oder so, da kannst du nichts machen, also das kriegst du
nicht raus, was da ist, wenn du jetzt alle, wenn prinzipiell aber alles funktioniert,
aber du kannst irgendwas nicht erreichen, dann kannst du Trace Route oder sowas machen
und hoffen, dass die Router auf dem Weg ICMP nicht geblockt haben, dann siehst du das,
wo du lang geroutet wirst und kannst dann wahrscheinlich auch so ungefähr sagen, wo es halt nicht
weiter geht.
Allerdings, wenn was nicht erreichbar ist, sollte eigentlich auch ein Router unterwegs,
also wenn es netztechnisch irgendwie gerade nicht da ist, unterwegs eine ICMP-Fehlermeldung
zurückliefern.
Wenn aber einfach nur der Server nicht antwortet, der Zielserver, dann kannst du einen Trace
Route machen und dann musst du halt bisschen raten danach.
Modam zeigt doch an, dass DSL aus ist, ne, da kannst du nichts machen, das muss dein
Provider klären.
Zum Glück habe ich noch eine Packung Sojasauce.
Dein Provider hat keine Ahnung, woran es liegt, also wenn dein DSL nicht synchronisiert, ist
dein Provider derjenige, der dafür zuständig ist.
Wenn die sagen, sie haben keine Ahnung, unfähig.
Ist das vielleicht die Telekom?
Ja das ist eine informales Tudo.
Genau.
So ich habe jetzt noch 3 Stück, 4 Stück, danach ist Schluss, dann wird weiter gegrindet.
So, ich habe jetzt noch 3 Stück, 4 Stück, danach ist Schluss, dann wird weiter gegrindet.
Aha, WWPD, erklär uns mal was da abgeht, für alle die die Leute nicht kennen, ich kenne
den nämlich nicht, ha nice, Linux, Linux C, ist das so gedacht, dass man das so ausspricht,
oder Linux C, Linux C, ha, Sushi ist nice, ich könnte es jetzt nicht jeden Tag oder jede
Woche ein paar mal essen, ja, aber so, also immer so einmal alle 2 Wochen oder so kann
man sich auch eine ordentliche Portion Sushi reinhauen, boah jetzt bin ich aber satt, letzte
Stück, so fertig, ich stelle das Zeug noch mal raus und die Kühlschweine jetzt weiter,
so.